i know this baby too well
the morning poop already came
wait a minute y'all gotta brush your
teeth cardi b is giving fans a peek
inside her life as a mom of two proving
stars
they really are just like us oh yes
honey on tuesday morning the 29 year old
rapper who welcomed her second child
with hubby offset back in september
proved that she's just like any other
mom up at the crack of dawn doing mom
things
the grammy winner walks her instagram
followers through her morning routine
which starts before 6 a.m feeding her
little one whose name they have yet to
reveal when bottle number one is done
she's on to prepping bottle number two
which she says she keeps in a cup of
room temperature water until around 8
a.m when he's up and it's time to eat
again oh snappity snap snap and if all
that didn't have moms around the world
saying hashtag relatable she shares this
clip
laughing and writing quote now he's
awake with full energy while i have none
feed burped changed adding waiting on
his morning poop though i know it's
coming and she wasn't wrong four minutes
later cardi posts an update literally in
my last pope i just say i'm waiting on
my morning poop i know this baby too
well
the morning poop already came
but the grammy winner and her little boy
weren't alone for long at 8 52 a.m
cardian offset's three-year-old daughter
culture and offset's six-year-old
daughter khalia were up and playing on
ipads i guess the girls woke up a little
bit earlier than i thought they would
wake up
wait a minute y'all gotta brush your
teeth
i'll hit your back up i'ma have to brush
this girl's teeth getting brushed she
normally wakes up like a dime
or ten but she's up now
cardi says that culture's normal
schedule is a little disrupted because
the family is currently out of town this
is not quite your normal
schedule
she usually goes to school in the
morning
but we're in georgia right now so yeah
it's a little different and with that
the [ __ ] wrappers morning got a little
busier than expected so the whole guide
through her routine was cut short quote
sorry can't do more insta stories it
gets busy quick need both my hands and
while cardi and offset haven't given
fans an official look at their newest
bundle of joy she did share a glimpse at
their baby boy in a 30th birthday shout
out dedicated to her husband i already
fell in love
the way that he was a dad already he's
really good and in december cardi shared
a sweet update on twitter writing quote
my son holding his bottle with both his
hands already i'm trying to remember if
kk was doing that around three months
old or if this is one of those super
powers these pandemic babies coming with
and back in 2019 she told et just how
much she loves being a mom
what does it mean to be a mother
it means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's like
like love joy it's a switch
you know what i'm saying there's like an
automatic smile so it's everything
[Music]
you